I think there's a lot of cool stuff that's gonna happen that we just can't see because we're held back by the bounds of the past. Well, you asked what's the point Jared. You asked what's the point of all our work. And the point is everything gets better. Just like when I look back to when I was a kid, like in the 70s, you know, it was really crummy and everything was just really crummy and boring. Right? And now everything's really bright and shiny and fun. This today is gonna look like the 70s in about 10 years. Gosh. Welcome to ADSP the Podcast episode 238 recorded on June 11th 2025. My name is Connor and today is another very short solo podcast episode pointing you towards some other podcasts that have been talking about AI LLMs and more. So as some of you know I listen to a ton of podcasts and recently there were three podcasts all roughly plus or minus on the same topic, which was AI, LLMs and the discourse
around them and the change that is coming because of them. And with this podcast, I basically want to point you at all three of these podcast episodes across the three different podcasts because I think you should go listen to them. Specifically one of them in particular which is one of the most recent podcasts from the changelog podcast. I imagine a certain percentage of the listeners of ADSP are aware of this. They recently had on Steve Yeggy, I believe it was on June 6th or just a few days ago. And he was on for an hour and a half talking about vibe coding, the death of the IDE and more.
And there's this clip right from the tail end of the podcast, which I'll play now. I think there's a lot of cool stuff that's gonna happen that we just can't see because we're held back by the bounds of the past. Well, you asked what's the point, Jared. You asked what's the point of all our work. And the point is everything gets better. Just like when I look back to when I was a kid,
like in the 70s, you know, it was really crummy and everything was just really crummy and boring, right? And now everything's really bright and shiny and fun. This today is going to look like the 70s in about 10 years. Gosh. And this is something that I have been talking to friends, family, my partner, my fiancee about and I think I've said this on the podcast before my dad's a journalist and He went from doing investigative reporting
basically by Going to different libraries. I grew up in a small town in northern British Columbia called Prince George. There is the public the Prince George Public Library, but then there's also two different libraries Via the colleges and universities. There's the UNBC library and the College of New Caledonia library Shout out to the education institutions of Prince George and I have memories of going along with my father to all three of these different libraries Because they had different books and you could do different types of research based on these books That's how investigative reporting used to be done. I remember one time, I think it was at CNC, the local college, he had these like microfilms and you'd have to pull them get the, you know,
librarians to pull them up from the back and then you had these machines and you'd be right, you'd be reading, you know, old newspapers on microfilms. Anyways, I don't fully understand it. The point being is that like you'd have to go around to these different places and get different resources because the internet was not a thing. And over my father's career, how he did his job completely changed. And I remember him telling me that when Google first became a thing that you could actually use usefully, it just completely upended the way that he did his job.
And he's never looked back the point being is that over a decade a couple decades the Landscape of how certain professions, you know do their job. It's unrecognizable and that clip that you know Steve is basically saying there I couldn't agree more like I don't think we can begin to fathom how different the world is going to look in a decade. And that is both exciting and scary. Anyways, I just I think people should start taking there's there's a lot of skeptics out there, which is what the the second two podcasts are talking more about. And I think if you if you listen to this podcast with Steve Yegge on ChangeLog you might be convinced and he also what you know he's a prolific writer he's
writing a book called Vibe Coding which I don't know when it's coming out but it's coming out at some point but also he wrote a very popular bog post almost a year ago I think it was back in June of 2024 called the death of the junior developer if you haven't read that I recommend you go read that as well. Interesting kind of to read it. H-having had like a year, uh, pass as well because at the time, you know, the LLM models that were out were, um, a lot less capable than the different, uh, models today, such as quad four. the different models today such as quad for the two other podcast episodes that I quickly want to mention are one from oxide and friends which I believe came out on June 4th. So just a couple days before the change log episode with Steve Yeggy this this is a podcast by Adam Levin fall and Brian Cantrell and they and other people from time to time
and they had on Steve Klaibnick who some of you will know is the co-author of the Rust programming language book as well as a number of other things current employee of Oxide and this Steve referred him as Klaibnick to disambiguate between Steve Yegge Klaibn nick wrote a blog entry recently called i am disappointed in the ai discourse just basically saying how there's like two groups of people people that are super pro ai and that people that are like it complete say that it completely doesn't work and he's basically lamenting on how it's impossible to have productive conversations with these groups of folks because they're kind of at odds with each other.
That was basically part one of a two part podcast, which part two happened on a different podcast called the fall through podcast. And if I didn't mention Oxide and Friends is the name of the podcast that the oxide folks do, Brian and Adam. And the fall through podcast is the reincarnation of the go time podcast Which is not a podcast that I actually really listened to until the tail end of it and they were winding that down It used to be a podcast in the changelog cinematic universe of podcasts. There's a ton of different ones Ship it I think is one of them brain
Time I think at one point was one of them. Brain Time, I think, at one point, was one of the changelog podcasts. Anyways, the changelog podcast is the flagship podcast of that cinematic universe of podcasts. They used to have one called Go Time. JS Party, that's another big one. Go Time got wound down and the folks behind that, I think some of them went and created the Fall Through podcast and they on Monday, which I believe is June 8 June 9th, just a couple days ago, basically had on Steve Klavnik as well to continue the conversation that happened on the oxide and friends podcast. So it's just interesting to
hear that I think it's a very interesting conversation in 2025, June 2025 that is, and it will continue to be an interesting conversation regardless of your thoughts on AI, LLMs, how it's going to affect the world. We'll leave it there. Go check those podcasts out. We've got changelog, we've got Oxide and Friends, and we've got fall through. And if you don't want to check the podcasts out, just listen to those episodes individually and then forget that those podcasts exist if you want. And I will link, you know, all of those in the description and the show notes as well as the blog post that Steve Yegge wrote a year ago and the blog that Steve Klavnik wrote just a few days
ago. Be sure to check these show notes either in your podcast app or at adspthepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode as well as a link to a get up discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast.
It's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.